to note that lizzo is responding to a
comment from some random person on
Twitter who no one's ever heard of lizzo
has fans who've fallen over her
constantly her comments and messages are
no doubt full of support and adulation
not to mention she has the entire media
apparatus that adores her she is loved
by Hollywood and pop culture she's been
hailed as a hero as beautiful and bold
by every corporate media outlet and yet
she decided to focus on this one comment
from this one person you know what you
choose to focus on you can't control is
a general life rule you can't control
what other people say about you or to
you you can control what you choose to
focus on